next question is from alex if i have to
cut weight for a powerlifting meet
what's the best way to go about it
in terms of performance uh let's say i'm
10 pounds over
and i have 16 weeks to go it's probably
a good spot to be in
option one slow cut a pound per week is
starting about eight to ten weeks out
so basically chill for a while and then
just do a pound a week leading into the
show
option two do that cut the first eight
to ten weeks and then just maintain
weight
going into the show and then option
three would be just chill for
15 minutes and do a big water cut at the
end
i'll take a crack at this and then i
want to hear your thoughts on it after
greg my my thing about water cuts
my concern is you you don't want to just
throw that in
not knowing how you perform in that
context so
there are some people that can do a
sizeable water cut
and still perform pretty well
everybody's got a number
that it's like if i water cut x number
of pounds i'm fine
if i cut x plus one i'm done
like i'm screwed yeah so you you want to
make sure that
it's almost like with bodybuilding with
a peak week strategy
you never want to try it the first time
when it matters
so um generally speaking i don't
advocate particularly large water cuts
and that
that goes back to when i coached
wrestlers i didn't like
my wrestlers doing large water cuts and
i i often just
advised against them so with power
lifting
it depends on your body size it depends
how well you
can accommodate water cuts but for me if
if i was a person competing around and
it depends
whether you're doing a meet with a
two-hour weigh-in or a 24-hour weigh-in
absolutely because those are very
different beasts absolutely
with a 24-hour weigh-in there is a lot
of flexibility
yeah if you get away with a lot if
someone wants to cut 10 pounds and they
have a 24 hour weigh-in
[ __ ] be my guess man like that's not
gonna be a fun water cut but like
pretty much everyone's going to be able
to pull it off you got plenty of time to
eat and rehydrate like you'll be fine
a 10 pound water cut with a two hour
weigh-in
who buddy no like that yeah that's gonna
suck
and you might be fine later in the day
by the time deadlifts roll around but
like
squats aren't gonna go well if you're
water cutting that much
yeah now the one the the approach here
that i would probably be
least fond of you know the water cut
again we already talked about the
factors that go into whether or not
that's an advisable approach
obviously don't do anything stupid don't
get yourself hurt don't end up in the
hospital
i don't i'm not fond of the idea of
cutting for the first eight to ten weeks
and then just
staying there for a while i i to me
that's kind of the worst of both worlds
you you took the time and patience to go
through the cut and then you just waited
there for
for eight to ten weeks and were kind of
miserable um i
in my opinion that's kind of the
probably the least advisable approach
what i would often do for for
most weight class sports um is generally
do a slow cut um
until you get within your comfortable
striking distance for a water cut so
like for me
if i were to compete around you know 180
pounds
i i personally wouldn't want to do a
water cut of more than like three to
five pounds
so what i would do is i would do a nice
slow cut and i would time it up so it's
nice gradual linear weight loss
and kind of shoot for within
you know maybe two weeks of the meat
getting to my
my comfortable weight that puts me in
striking distance
i would do it two weeks before to just
give myself some wiggle room because
you know sometimes things happen and
body weight is
annoying and you're like oh i didn't get
there in time so
my approach would be generally do a nice
comfortable
linear drop and once you get to that
place where you're within a water cut
striking distance i would just chill
there but i wouldn't plan to get there
too far out ahead because now you're
just
holding weight that you know it's not
your natural weight it's not the weight
that you enjoy being at
yeah i think that i think that's another
key consideration
like you mentioned natural weight i
think that another important
consideration
is where you see yourself being weight
wise
after the meat so for example if you're
you know if you weigh something and it's
heavier than you would ideally like to
be
and you're thinking like you know i want
to move down a weight class and stay
there
and maybe eventually move down two
weight classes because i have a
considerable amount of fat to cut
then i would approach that differently
than you know if
if you're like quite competitive and
your natural
walking around weight is 215
but you compete at 205 in power lifting
then you know after the meet you're
probably going to be getting back up to
215
and so you you probably don't want to
cut early and maintain an unnatural
weight for
multiple weeks leading into the meat
which which
is far away from where you feel good and
comfortable and then
you know have to move back up after that
so
if someone is like actually trying to
decrease weight
and wants to be like at the weight that
their meat is at
or below that weight for you know
an indefinite period of time after the
meet then i would say go ahead and take
care of the cut on the front end
and go with that that option too the
slow cut for the first eight to ten
weeks and then maintenance after that
because you know then at that point kind
of your true body weight
is the competition weight and if you
want to keep moving lower after that
you know then you're kind of taking what
amounts to like a six week diet break
competing at the top of that weight
class and then continuing to move down
after that um that's a good point
because i answered under the assumption
that
that you are not now just assuming a new
body weight yeah
i was under the assumption that you're
you're going back to normal
after the meet yeah for sure or in and
if
if that is the case like if the weight
you compete at
is below what your natural body weight
is and you're planning on getting back
up to your natural weight
after you compete uh then i very very
much agree with what trek said